all right i got a brand new hour of
stand-up comedy tickets on sale right
now san francisco september 8 to the
10th all the tickets almost gone
tarrytown sold out we got madison
wisconsin milwaukee wisconsin chicago
illinois minneapolis minnesota london is
sold out dublin is sold out belfast
still some tickets we may add shows of
the uk in october christy comedy.com for
all the tiki wikis thanks for the
support
black blocker all right
all my tickets are on sale right now i'm
supposed to be filming my special in the
spring of 23 so if you want to see the
special before it's filmed come on out
canada for the first time in october uh
hamilton and toronto toronto second show
added then we're going to richmond
virginia and hershey pa hershey pa
second show added knoxville uh atlanta
and uh birmingham atlanta second show
edit that's with adam ray
louisville and evansville in november
and then we got florida and california
in december california is you guys been
asking me to come in sacramento san jose
and santa rosa so come on out
jacksonville all on sale right now at
[Music]
don't run savolcanocomedy.com from your
feelings babe don't be afraid don't be
ashamed don't hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe come on
let's celebrate
we're
all right what's up babe it's
of course you guys were waiting
celebrating our 93rd episode yes
93rd episode so you know special app
tonight everyone's 93rd app is special
you guys asked for it and we're giving
it to you we got the we got the mail we
got the the physical mail in the mail we
got the emails we got the dms you guys
wanted something special for the special
93rd episode we got you guys part you
know coming up to us when you see us in
the streets saying what are we doing for
93 what's going on this is what we're
doing we're going to celebrate we're
going to have a girls night we're going
to have an us day in us day we're going
to have a spa day a spa day
that's it so we feel good we feel good
we look good self-care 93. self-care
don't care 93 there's a lot of good
things first of all 1993 let's talk
about world trade center bombing
absolutely uh 36 chambers came out 36
chambers came back i want to say little
giants came out could have been 1994 it
is my favorite movie i use these for
intimidation i use these remember the
annexation of puerto rico
[Laughter]
what is the best things that came out
that jurassic park was the most popular
film bridges of madison county love
best-selling fiction book 60 minutes was
the top tv show unfortunately i don't
know
seinfeld won the emmy
uh eric clapton's tears in heaven won
the gram for the song of the year oh my
god that was a sad [ __ ] song sad sets
off all right sad song say so much elton
john
okay you know it don't know it yes you
do
yes you do this one you do i bet money
on it i don't have my phone sad song say
so much pimp do you know what pimp
i don't dude i know we're not gonna hop
on this but i i just have to because
this one there's no way you don't know
this in a way reminds me of elton john
i've never been more correct in my life
right i swear to god doesn't pimp remind
you of elton john i swear to god dude
you just blew my balls off gone you
remind me of elton [ __ ] john i'm
yeah i'm like ray leo to meet elton john
yes you are ray leota meets you you are
yeah you're ellen john with ray leota's
heart
okay here we go
oh yes isn't that the intro from perfect
strangers no oh you're a friend and a
confidant
no that's that's golden girls you don't
know what it's not no i do know and but
that's not the theme song from the
golden girls no the golden girls is
thank you for being a friend
travel down the road and back again your
heart is true you're a proud
you would see the biggest gift would be
for me and the card attached would say
thank you for being hey babe
there he goes okay not very often do you
get two intro songs it's a spot let me
tell you something right now i am
sweating
do you have do we almost need like some
type of like oh i might pass out i need
something to like want like like a cream
or something i brought
bev we have we have okay let's talk
about we have first we have we got
products you brought champagne flutes
and white wine
champagne flutes and white wine is
whatever okay you brought that okay i
bought that i brought
i got i went to lush
and i got a face mask and they make it
for you and then you have to use it by a
certain time okay okay and it was it was
expired on your birthday
it was 26. three days ago
three four days ago so it's and i have a
lot left so i figure we do a mint a mint
mask
okay spa
champagne flute's mint mask i just was
fun too brought some mad lips why not
maybe we play medals maybe we'll see if
this thing holds up us day maybe we
laugh maybe we we say this sucks we
don't know if this is what being lizzo
feels like i love it i signed me up
um do you do you should we take our ass
out i'll pull my ass out right now do
you think that though do you think
that
you know me with
expired medication
is an expired face mask are we worried
this is not expired three days is not
expired this is not expired medica first
of all it's not medicaid
well i disagree because the spa day is
medication okay you're right i also
brought what's this
from if you remember from last episode i
brought
the hot sauces babe
that are ready to kill us so we can do
that too i don't know if you wanna do it
today another day but i brought it i
don't need to put you on the spot but
will you do this when you do the
ayahuasca yes or no i need it in three
seconds yes okay just behave this has
been hey babe
um
yes okay okay so let's yeah this is what
the mask has in it you say it's
medication it has
honey
talc adoki beans
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
uh
this and that it has it's all natural
[ __ ] um what isn't a dookie bean i've
never heard of one i've ever never heard
of a duke but we're gonna put it on our
face
azuki this is a dookie it is no this
says i'm sorry this literally says
a-d-u-k-i
unless this is a lush did a misprint
this says a dookie hey dude yeah that's
what this says
oh wow
that first ingredient look how it's
spelled
a dookie there's no z in that
ground a dookie beans uh hello lash if
you're watching and we know that you are
you have the number one ingredient and
your mint mask is misspelt i actually
quality control
what we did find the right oh it is
there isn't a dookie so there's an aduki
bean and a natsuki bean yep onesie it's
it's like the difference between syria
and uh syria yeah very hard okay
so
this is uh we're going to look like uh
the ghost from ghostbusters though it's
green it's a matte oh my god look at
your pants that's why you think i wore
these pants today unbelievable
your color story by the way today 10 out
of 10. this by the way these pants i'm
gonna give free promo to company right
now but i genuinely believe in built
bylt yeah i think it's built.com best
pants i've ever had in my life
they're not even a sponsor they are not
a sponsor wow i love them and i'm
wearing a built t-shirt
what do you
do
you find companies and you go in hard
and i and i spend my money on them you
do i don't even ask them why are the
pants great do you like the way they're
cut i like the way they're cut i like
the way they're tapered i like the way
they make me feel um they're not genes
they're
much more breathable
you move i like yeah
um they're not um um
they're not uh uh they don't they don't
make me feel fat yeah they make me feel
thin because important i got a little
room in the way like you ever have a
real fat day and then you put on loose
clothings and you feel skinny many
immediately yeah what's up like i feel
thin immediately let's eat yeah let's
see i'm ready yeah i'm ready to go i
will say i've been falling into a trap
especially more recently of a lot of
dark clothing like blacks blues dark
greys a lot of blacks and i will tell
you that it's refreshing to see
different colors top and bottom like
that it just brings out an energy in
people
that is different yeah it's different
it's it's it's channeling a bit of
homeless pimp color scheme you want to
talk about color schemes oh yeah there's
not even you can't you can't nail down a
color scheme for him when homeless pimp
really has an outfit he comes in on you
can't even tell he's human you're like
no you don't know what race he is he
looks he literally is appropriating
everybody yeah it's almost like just
move on from this one
it literally looks like like he just
looks like a bag of skittles exploded
they didn't like me out in joshua tree i
was wearing the sunflowers did not they
said no crackhead one crackhead swung at
my car and punched the front of my face
is there a temperature that it could get
to where you would consider wearing
shorts or you just refused no i wish
yeah i wore shorts oh you wore shorts
yeah because i'm always working with you
guys you can wear shorts shorts we're
the type of company you can wear it's a
comedy role i feel like you know
i mean you can i mean do you wish
you have an issue taking up a bloom cafe
if your office does not only wear shorts
to work i want you to go on bloom cafes
yelp right now
give a five-star review of one of the
balloon cafes items that you ate and
then tell us why your boss should let
you wear shorts i mean really dig in too
don't just write a sentence yeah dig in
and out on the yelp on bloom cafes yell
but you have to give them five stars and
you have to shout out one of their items
um
why don't we put a little mask on i'm
ready to mask up
because i've been oh
yeah before we do that we have stuff we
put the mask do we tell them the big
news i think we do
the mask first put the mask on and then
immediately throw us that hat when it's
on okay i brought this because we might
need to wipe our hands oh and it will
have and pimples all saying have some
wine well you know what used to be a
waiter why don't you [ __ ] pour it for
[Laughter]
yo pimp's a wine snob he tells you if
that one sucks or not
i usually do this in the middle didn't
she used to i'll be your mirror
looks good so far didn't you used to
right now you look at your like you're
fighting at war
it looks like like you're getting ready
for battle didn't you used to pimp say
that used to deliver wine to famous
people what is the most expensive bottle
of wine you delivered to someone uh five
thousand dollars a bottle five thousand
dollars a bottle have you ever
disrespectful
yeah and then too much money right
that client was a famous artist and he
he got really mad um because kanye came
over and drank the whole case and left
and how many bottles are in the case 12.
so he was getting sixty thousand dollar
cases of wine uh yes six that i had to
carry into his wine cellar so if i trip
you're you're on the hook for 60.
they have this famous like the wine
selection is very famous and they have a
wine angel they call it go get you the
wine and i think they i
i'm remembering from 20 years ago it's
either a machine oh but i think it's not
i think there's a person that hooks up
to a strap and there's a huge glass
case that goes all the way to the
ceiling of wines and they hook in and
they fly up and get you
is this place still open ariel yes where
is it it's in mandalay bay and there's
one in new york city but the wine angel
is in mandalay bay
wine angel a-u-a-u-e
r-a-u-r-e-o-l-e a-u-r
las vegas and then type wine angel
pimp typed in areola las vegas okay so
did you see that photo right there
extreme
there it is
and this has been around for years i i
20 like 15 plus years ago i
oh my god oh i walked past this the
other night
in vegas the other night yeah i was in
vegas like two nights ago
what
you were in vegas two nights ago yeah i
drove i flew out of vegas after joshua
tree oh that's right yeah i remember you
flying home when you went to joshua tree
to hang out
no i took a girl on four dates and then
we went to joshua tree and yeah wow
how was the dates
good is she a prospect
definitely a prospect
new york based
yeah she took me the fairy hawks game
interesting oh she is she from where is
she from originally well i do fireworks
on a weekend i feel like talking about
our romance right now this is what you
do in an us day let's talk [ __ ] yes
is it am i evenly applied to god i don't
know no you're perfect look great
perfect okay here we go
any um start to feel the mint it tingles
just put it on like you'll never take
off freedom oh my god you gotta you
gotta do have to spread it you can't you
can't it's wasteful if you don't
you guys look like mascots getting ready
for work
yeah go get your forehead get you know
yeah get you get your sides and really
really yeah really spread it hey you're
getting great oh you're great you did
great you think i'm good at this i feel
like you've this isn't the first time
you've applied mass today that much
first time i've ever applied a physical
mask i have applied masks emotionally
yeah but physically first time i've ever
done this you really are thorough uh and
efficient thank you okay so now do i rub
the recipe in on my hands i would rub it
in and then if and then and then clean
your hands off with that oh no no no
[Laughter]
yeah do you do you feel the mince
working yet
yes of course
it's your day
um self-care
i feel like um you feel dementor right i
almost feel
like it
it's giving me like this awakening like
because the mint is going directly
finalizes your epiderm i'm revitalizing
right yeah i feel fully revitalized now
the question i think we're gonna need to
ask you pimp is on camera does it
resemble wearing blackface no no no okay
it's not the intention here we're safe
then we're in green yeah very kermit
face oh kermit is great can we throw
this in the fridge yeah sure i
appreciate that very bench sit would you
you want to do you want to apply
something
you're welcome to
it's it's i'm telling you right now
it is that's great that's even better
that's even better
you don't know that pimp is actually in
a robe and a hat and a towel too but
you'll never see him
by the way the towel i've never in my
life put a towel on my head this way do
you frequently wear your
tap dry your hair like this
um i haven't in recent times but in my
life most certainly i've not once in my
life ever had a towel wrapped on my head
like this not once in my life and you
could you could google chris's stefano
towel head you won't find you know what
you just do it out of the shower and
i'll tell you why some people say that
if you really go like this a lot you're
gonna split ends you're gonna you're
gonna frazzle your hair a bit you're
gonna my hair is frazzled so if you do
this it has a way of absorbing it and
you're drying it right on by the way
you're multitasking because now you're
drying it on your own time i'm sure yeah
this is you're going about your business
this is doing well walk around i'd love
to see what my hair looks like
wet when it dries out of this because i
wonder if it would just look like a like
a mr softy snow cone it doesn't it's not
going to get bone dry you're going to
take it off it's going to be nice and
damp and i'll tell you what it's going
to be it's going to be primed for
styling
wow
damp
not wet
putting hair product in dry hair is a
big no-no
you not you need to put hair product in
damp hair
it's usually where yeah fellas if you
didn't know that already this is also
out of context christopher google krista
stefano towel had out of context funny
on a clip too
nothing came up by the way these are
great these are great yeah i i i blacked
them out i wanted to write s and c on
them but i forgot oh like okay yeah
um but this is good now what now now
just by the poor pimp is this one piece
of [ __ ] wine no this is hypebeast wine
from australia oh australia now i'm
going for the first time to do shows in
australia the first two weeks of
december tickets on sale soon sal you've
been to australia how did you do that
have you ever done new zealand but it is
oh new zealand it's that white for like
thirty five dollars yeah yeah have you
ever done
it
nice it's nice have you ever done comedy
in australia i have not i've been to
australia have you been in new zealand
no they got me on a show in auckland new
zealand too
no way i swear to god
the flight from australia to new zealand
though is not bad
but it's it's not it's quick i think
it's like how long is i i think i think
it might still be like a five hour well
it depends what part but here's the
thing when you go to australia you know
they're like oh you'll do shows in
sydney and perth and melbourne and this
and that and you're like okay i'll just
be there you have to get on five-hour
flights like you could fly in new york
to l.a yeah you're flying baby flying
all over that journey you flew all over
that country when you got there all over
that country i went to five places
so how many hours of flight time were
you in like you would get be in a place
and then have to take a five-hour flight
with the time zones changing right like
just like new york la uh i don't know if
it changes from australia to new zealand
though
i don't know but there's a challenge new
zealand might be the most beautiful
place in the world brisbane is the other
place i'm going to wait when are you
going to new zealand first two weeks of
december you want to come
[Laughter]
i would love nothing more but i'll be
filming but my friend is down there
filming a new television series
um and he's there he's awesome
he's a writer director his name is ian
morris he he created the in-betweeners
it's a huge smash hit in uh it was a
television show comedy in in england and
they made two or three movies out of it
and he's buddies with like um flight of
the concords and both from new zealand i
think actually jimmy carr yeah i think
jimmy carr officiated his wedding he
he's and taika all the guys from what we
do in the shadows he's in that whole
click he's making the show it's called
um
we should go you know what we should do
if we go
we go to australia too we should do a
hey babe episode where obviously you
can't be there but i i do it with a
koala bear
as as the coast
that's it you're my little come on
right now email the pod heybaypod
gmail.com does sal resemble a koala bear
more than every other comic or remind
you of koala bear more than any other
comic koala is a dangerous bite by the
way real serious answers only we're not
playing games here
what would lead anyone to believe that
we're playing games
i just sometimes i think people think
you know do i gotta that's why flex
specs
flex packs flex packs tm
trade market flex packs
oh that could be like a workout thing
you take on shark tank like sharks
who wants to flex specs with me laurie
um okay oh look they are they're fussy
eaters just like sally baby
yeah they're cute but i think they i
think they're real like they're bad um
i'll tell you he's filming a new show
called time bandits he did he's there
until february 23. so okay
i'll link you guys now sal here's the
thing we're doing a lot of a lot of fun
things for 93 for app 93. one thing you
wanted to do
is
what we all want to do but you had
brought a very kind of it's a hay
trademark now of the present moment hat
that got a lot of laughs that got that
went viral
you guys know it the hat it's the hat
that
what episode number was it just in case
just in case you've been sleeping under
a rock i think it was 90 or 89 90 or 89
we put this hat on and it was the
shallowest hat we've ever seen it see
i know we're saying it's the style today
but the style today i think they hired a
new seamstress on this day that they
made this hat they messed up the hat
it's you know it's it's a very it's a
very shallow hat and do you know that
after
after we spoke about it on hey babe
props to bodega the store in the awesome
streetwear store in boston they reached
out to me and they refunded me for the
house
and it was like 50 clams too it wasn't
even like 50 clams they refunded for the
hat
shout out to you guys shout out to you
guys the idea that we had
is
we want to give this hat yes to
someone's going to win it someone's
going to win it one lucky fan what we
want you guys to do is long unused
unused and that that is the hat that sal
wore that i wore that is the hat this is
the game warren hay bay born hat that's
right this is not a replica this is hey
babe warn you you'll be able to smell
the mint now this is a hero hat they use
it on camera
what we need you to do
is reenact yes your favorite moment from
hey babe
film it
post it tag at hey babe pod no i got it
we got to think of a good hashtag for
this target what i'm saying we want them
to tag the instagram at heybaypod and
email it to heybaypad gmail right how
should we do it how should we collect it
what do you guys think i think
instagram's most popular instagram i
mean i think at heybay pod you tag
heybaypod we see it upload it to
instagram upload it don't don't email us
upload the instagram how about hashtag
uh
hey babe stupid hat what about hayley93
hashtag hey babe 93. well yeah but we
want people to
to well shouldn't be connected to this
you think okay how about hashtag hey
babe stupid hat okay now let's do
hashtag so that is the hashtag people
make sure we get it out there hashtag
hey babe stupid hat reenact your
favorite moment your favorite
conversation piece that sal and i have
had from episode one faye babe all the
way through to this one all the way
through to the historic 93rd episode
when we celebrate meta as [ __ ]
do this do this conversation right now
that's what i'm just this is this is the
kind of creativity we're looking for
that's what it is and you could do it
you know you could just do the
conversation you could do the
conversation with props with costumes
however you want to do it you could do
it by yourself you could do with
somebody else get creative hashtag hey
babe stupid hat let's give them what
this comes out in uh
where this comes out today is
it comes out september 8th i think this
maybe to the end of september here's
what we'll do you got to the end of
september why don't we give them why
don't we give them yeah we'll give them
to the end of september we'll give them
to september 30th to do this
we why don't we do this why don't we
pick the top three on october 1st and on
that hey babe episode pull up the top
three let the fans decide yeah who the
winner is
let the fans decide i say
i'll say if we get even even great ones
we'll do we'll do all of them we'll take
the whole we'll take the whole one to do
it
so so and then you will be sent this hat
and then we expect you
to take pictures with this hat all over
the world wherever you go and you and
you send it to us and you send it to us
and then you'll win the hat yes and
i'm i'm excited about that actually
fell off it was literally i see i see it
um
one thing i know about sal he loves meat
oh my god i love it and it's and there's
only one thing that can can can really
really satisfy my meat cravings and it's
butcher box box
butcher subscription service
subscription service for meats
i mean chicken grass-fed beef organic
pork race crate freak wild caught
seafood uh grass-fed beef humanely
raised no antibiotics no added hormones
the best
portions of meat that you can get and
you don't got to go to the store you
gotta go you gotta know what you know
how to what it should look like when
it's perfect whether this is not the
other it goes it comes right to your ass
you choose how much you want or you
could choose the pre-portioned packages
they send up to 14 pounds and i got it
in the freezer and then guess what all
of a sudden i'm like can i have a
hankering for a pork chop and i said do
i need to go to the store no i know
there's a lot of options out there i
know i got a lot of choices but if i'm
going to eat a box it's butcher box
that's right
and get just what you want delivered
right to your door it's free shipping
and the continental unit amazing there
are no surprise fees choose from a
variety of box plans
from curated to customize and change the
plan whenever you want whenever you want
to do it okay uh yes it's amazing
butcher box you're gonna get free
chicken for a year
oh my god
literally take chicken breasts off your
grocery list right now you will get free
chicken for a year two pounds of free
range organic chicken breasts for free
in every order when you sign up at
butcherbox.com
an incredible deal that they've never
offered before free chicken for a year
at butcherbox.com hey babe clean this
deal at butcherbox.com i mean i don't
want to like insult anybody but if you
don't claim this deal
you're not playing with a full deck what
are you doing if i gave you the
opportunity i said you wanna can i give
you free chickens for a year who would
say that nobody would say that
butcherbox.com hey babe free chicken for
a year i would say what do i have to do
and like i would i would really do stuff
for it and all you got to do with this
that's it that's it that's it butcher
box the box you always want to eat
football fans the first sunday of the
nfl season is here thank god draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a cannot miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season i
am so excited right now new customers
can bet just five dollars and get two
hundred dollars in free bets
instantly that's five dollars and get
two hundred thousand free bets instantly
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code hey babe to get
two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet this sunday that's code hey bae only
at draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restriction
restrictions apply see show notes for
details go down and look in the show
notes what's the promo code one more
time hey babe
now i think first of all 93rd episode
uh i didn't know
not a lot of people get to 93. no it's
fun to make it to 93. and kind of still
feel as good as i felt maybe even better
than when we were at one we're rocking
and rolling rocking and rolling we're
still having fun we're still having fun
and you're still the one the one and
we're still having fun are you still 93
yeah
um i mean this podcast has been through
a pandemic yeah a war yeah uh um
a a super bowl infestation of lantern
flies infestation of lanternflies which
the uh new york uh government has said
you should kill kill them that's an
insect you have to unfortunately i
killed hundreds hundreds i can never
catch these [ __ ] yeah they jump by the
way derosa's team lanternfly we found
that out
derozan's once they're beautiful and he
doesn't see the no he doesn't see why
you should kill them they're destroying
trees and crops and they have no value
to us whatsoever yeah i want to say joe
what happens if they eat the all the
tomatoes that you need for your store
yeah that you should be giving five
stars to it joey roses what are you
doing yeah what are you doing we also
went through kane's death we went
through kane tanaka's death a lot of big
things happened a lot of big things all
of the berlin wall the
technically yes right yeah um
come on through
uh alex trebek passed away
unfortunately okay
uh lucy who who was the sponsor is no
longer a company
no yeah no no longer a company no i
swear to god that's upsetting because
they have lozenges gum and and packs
they've got pomegranate flavors they
have cinnamon they got blueberry and if
you if you're using nicotine already
this is an alternative and if you had
just went when they were officially
accompanied to lucy.com and put in the
promo code hey baby we've got a nice
discount and you know what it's code.com
and i wonder if that led to the downfall
only lucy knows are they really not a
company i've heard
they're not a company if they are
they should be happy with this right
because we're we're giving a free promo
yeah but if they're not then what did
they pay us everything they needed to
pay us that's a question for the lawyer
okay
um i
i i
but this podcast i never thought we'd
get to 93. and you know what i'm telling
you right now i'm almost guaranteeing it
we're going to do another 93. i i
believe that i don't see why not why
when do you think it'll end
everything has an end everything we're
not going to do it till we're 100 years
old we're not going to keen like do you
know what i think you know what i think
it'll end you know what i think
poetically we'll end it at yeah i think
we'll end it
at 500 episodes you think so i think
we'll get to 500. wow that's a long time
i think it can be done it's 10 years
520 eps is 10 years right i see i see no
reason why we can't do it
wow i say 10 year old podcast out there
dude joe rogan's out like his 2000th
episode yeah but doesn't he do like five
a week yeah two or three a week yeah
yeah so i know we can't do that it's a
bit excessive yeah but you don't know
maybe time's a change yeah times are a
change you know that song though this is
billy joel
no
no i thought that was weren't you
singing um bob dylan
oh yeah right yeah i saw billy joel in
concert by the way oh yeah two weeks ago
got black black out drunk of course you
did i wasn't with you here he goes
he brought out swear to god he brought
out uh in the middle of the show i guess
he always brings out a special guest he
brought out olivia rodrigo
who is i've only heard the name in a
joke she's a young sensation 19 year old
beautiful girl the guy behind me asked
his wife who's this guy
i said that's a 19 year old girl
who's a beautiful gorgeous girl
she comes out and he goes honey who's
this guy
because i guess she thought billy joel
said olivia rodriguez
so he goes who's this guy and then the
wife goes you can clearly see it's a
girl
wow that's a strong close up yeah yeah
yeah you think olivia arrigo even knows
who like billy joel is she has a song in
the lyric where billy joel uh she says
something about billy joel so i think
her parents are big fans he actually
came out and sang uptown girl she came
out saying uptown girl with him so it's
pretty cool awesome yeah you went to the
garden
did you get hooked up or did you no
hooked up through live niche they hooked
me up shout out shout out um joanne from
live nation
square garden thank you yeah i love i
love that whole team over there yeah i
think i don't think was live nation i
think it was actually from the garden
shout out joanne did you you were right
you were in a suite a box no they they i
actually requested to be in because i
wanted to be that's what
it was just us it was just us in the row
what do you mean it was just you in the
row it was it was a little row it was
like one of those four seaters that they
have they have and it was me jazz brian
morton and nick the ear
yeah i reserved comment
nick the ear nick the ear he's um he has
no ear no he has two he has two did we
call him the ear cause he's always
listening it's like a listening device
okay yes okay and shout out nick wait so
we
have a question so are you dancing what
was your what did you end up doing at
the nineteenth probably dancing because
i wasn't there
[Laughter]
right so because it was because sal was
nowhere to be found who let loose i let
loose
i got no i i fully blacked out drunk
again did you remember the concert
i remember i re he saying i'm moving out
anthony's song and then i i moved out
yeah
so i don't remember the end he sang
piano man i have zero recollection i
woke up do it out here on piano man
i said i i went to see him two or three
times at the garden over the course of
his tenure there and piano man's great
at in that moment but piano man is the
if i had to pick one song i was like i'm
i i want to hear something else
but but i feel like it's it's the song
if you don't sing it kind of he said he
came out he was funny he came out he
said tonight we're going to play the old
[ __ ] because he hasn't wrote a new you
know he has no new song so it's all the
whole [ __ ] so it's funny he goes tonight
we're going to play the old [ __ ] and he
goes i'd like to thank harry styles for
taking a night off he had like good bits
and then he does he's such an amazing
performer because he does things there's
one song he's singing where he's he's
going listen this song i forgot what the
song was he goes this song requires me
to hit a high note and he goes i'm 73
years old he goes i'm gonna need your
guys help to hit this high note he goes
if i hit this high note i'm telling you
you know building it up i can't hit this
high note but knowing that he can of
course hit that high note it's a build
up to get the fans involved when he hit
that high note the place
erupted
erupted where it gave me the chills
and i'm like do you remember the song i
know as a performer that's a bit he does
that every night and it was and he nails
the high note
and it was and he's like thank you guys
so much it was beautiful i don't
remember the song oh cause there's a lot
of billy joel songs that i don't know
like i know the hits but there's a lot
of ones i bet you'd be the same you're
like i don't know this one he did
obscure him i know every song you know
like obscure songs from the 1975 i know
non-hits i know b-sides but i don't know
like there's some screws i don't know
yeah right but so so so we got what gave
you the idea to go
um because i've been literally saying i
gotta get back there now that he's back
and everything i guess
you don't want to miss it it wasn't it
wasn't even my idea was uh uh emilio was
my manager aka the italian woman she got
me tickets um to billy joel um because
we listened to billy joel on the way
drive home from montreal after i was
pulled over by the lewis county police
department um
so he was like i'll get you tickets i
gotta connect and then they got me
tickets for my birthday what i would
like to cordially invite you to is i was
given tickets to the 1975 concert my
favorite band november 7th msg would you
like to come that's a monday that is a
month i know because my birthday is
november 6th would you like to come for
your birthday to see my favorite band
is it in the evening 7 p.m so my
family's visiting from the west coast
they leave that that that
afternoon
so i might be able to swing that
actually can i get back to you in a day
or two
you're a swinger get back to me where is
it at msg i don't know any of their
songs
the 1970 you would love that yeah you
look i mean you like we like similar
music you like pop you like whitney
houston you like do they sound like when
you use it they're inspired by whitney
houston no they're not they're for
google 1975 inspired by whitney houston
by the way
1975 from the city of nuketown of
newcastle england i want to try to go to
newcastle when i'm in the uk
beautiful yeah it's great
they're from newcastle we talked about
this i think yeah the 1910 our records
sound more like whitney houston than the
smiths wow there you go i'm here for it
maddie healey lead singer love do they
know you yet
so
i was told by
you look like you look like mary
magdalene
you literally look like you just put a
savior in a basket and pushed him down
the road
you you
so i was told but unfortunately
that
by a comic i'll tell you all fair
because i want to add them but but you
know who knows in 1975 very well said i
was with them
uh one day and i think they might have
been in america this is pretty pandemic
uh he goes i was with them and the
drummer i believe he said knows your
comedy and he said was talking about
your 911 clip
and we played your 911 clip and the
drummer and the band and the people are
laughing so funny matty healey the lead
singer
who's you know
woke and all respect love him did not
find
my humor is not his cup of english tea
so he he walked away i was like not for
me you're not his earl grey which hurts
it [ __ ] but nothing about your 9 11
story
was offensive
you can edit that out
so um
so
i i don't know what it was but
and listen it hurt it i would love the
opportunity to maybe get a chance to
meet the band and do a different bit and
and yeah do a different bit
do a different bit and just get to know
them and talk to them and let them see
me as a human being yeah because they
are
not not even close my number one the
only musician the only album the only
music i've ever listened to that's
actually spoke to me and actually helped
me get through a tough time that's why
i'm so connected to them i never use
music in that way before other than the
1975. so i would love
uh to get um an opportunity to meet them
that night i was told by the people who
got me the tickets who are very up there
like look we can get you in no problem
get you great seats it is up to the band
who who makes it who's not and i said
i've been there i know not that i've
been a master square garden yeah but i
know what it is
not everyone can just come in but i'd
love
if 1975 you're listening and we know
that they are we know that you are
please let me backstage i want to i want
to do the 911 bit for maddie healy to
especially let's do it like can you can
you open with it for them
the secret put it out into the world
it's msg
it's my hometown yeah i think i open
with the 911
my hometown my hometown who is it
springsteen oh did i get it
yeah yeah i didn't think you were going
to get you by the way really music
really putting this out in the ready for
this yeah putting this out into the
world yeah for this first day a couple
of hours and half all this
our father who are in heaven hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven give us
our day our daily bread and forgive our
trespasses as we figure those who
trespass against us lead us on
implantation but deliver us from
do you ever say that because i had to go
the other day to church for something
did you ever do you ever
and be like i don't know what i'm saying
did you ever dissect the words to hail
mary and i mary mother of god pray for
us sinners now at the hour of our death
amen
you i think you just gave like one line
i think i just gave marriage to the hail
mary lord be glory be to the father to
the son to the holy spirit as it was in
the beginning is now and never shall be
the world
amen so listen to all these things what
are you saying i want to go back to this
by the way don't forget where you what
it's another adhd thing okay
this podcast brought to you by
betterhelp absolutely always we
talk about this mental health is is is
what we practice today it's a little
mental health a little we had
guess who gave us the idea to have an us
day a self-day self-care day our
counselors at better health that's right
thank you so much because you need to
take time for yourself we need to
de-stress we need to take time to
rejuvenate ourselves our minds our
brains our bodies uh you get stuck on
all the stresses we're all there all day
everyone's got their own set of problems
and not enough people say time out
take something for me right now and then
better help does a great job of doing
it's better help not better health
better help and it can be tough for your
brain you know a lot of our brains they
try to stay in problem-solving mode all
day all day all day got to relax take a
chill pill find your own solutions babe
there's no better feeling and what i
love about better betterhelp is that you
could do it from the comfort and privacy
of your own home you don't have to go to
an office nobody knows about this it's
between you and your counselor and the
licensed therapist and a licensed
therapist and they're all licensed you
don't even have to turn the camera on
you could why not
let me tell you something right now i
want you to go on better help right now
i want you to keep the camera off and i
want you to do what's you want to do
about naked do it but naked nobody cares
about nick no i'm butt naked right now
talking with you it's butt naked or buck
naked
it's butt i think it's butt naked but
then in rap
songs naked
if you're thinking of giving therapy a
try better help is a great option less
stress be more confident if you're more
like yourself just vent just vent get
matched with a therapist after filling
out a brief survey and switch therapists
anytime and you get a great discount
which is what i love about doing this
podcast how not only can we give you
guys websites and and and companies that
will help you but we can it's affordable
we can help you it's affordable to begin
with but we make it even more affordable
here at the show yes better if you visit
betterhelp.com hey babe today you're
going to get 10 off your first month
that's
betterhelp.com 10 off your first month
you want to be a better problem solver
therapy can get you there betterhelp.com
slash hey vape
ridge wallet we got a new sponsor right
now this episode is brought to you by
ridge wallet ridge wallet you hold it in
your hand right now dude you know what
the best thing yes it's it's it's it's
beautiful carbon fiber burnt titanium
can hold up to 12 cards plus room for
cash all that is true you could tell
there's 30 styles in columns let me tell
you the main thing about this fifty
thousand five star reviews that okay you
know that you can get your cards
pick-potted pick-pocketed digitally they
can steal your information stand next to
you put their phone next to your wallet
and steal all your info off your cards
that's the new that's the new jam ridge
wallet has technology in here protects
from digital pick pocketing that is the
number one reason honestly forget of
course yes all the other things how good
it is how durable it is how sleek it is
digital pick pocketing can not get my
influence it's more prevalent now than
regular pip of course how are you gonna
pickpocket you can't pickpocket me now
my pants are too tight
so they're so confident that you like it
actually they'll let you try for 45 days
it's the rfid that's what's called the
blocking technology right that protects
you from the digital pickpocket do you
know what's you ready for this sal yeah
like this is such an amazing offer the
second part that i swear i'm i went and
bought my own with our own promo code
just to be in just to be entered into
the sweepstakes a special bonus for the
listeners with every dollar spent on the
website before september 30th you'll be
entered to win a brand new upgraded ford
bronco or 75 000 in cash if i win i'm
taking the bronze unbelievable broncos
are sick winner will be announced
announced in october now i got some rich
products i got the wallet okay i got the
key uh the key holder which is awesome
you fold all your keys in this little
little slim thing they all fit together
beautiful and i got this i'm not joking
you never think about pens
they have this pen it's like this big
it's like it's made of the titanium it's
durable and it goes right in your pocket
it's like fun to click and it's it's a
dope ass pen and i got it and i use it
all the time and i went on the website
to order and the bronco uh the all the
the the sweepstakes of the bronco was
right there right and the new bronco if
you haven't seen it and you asked joe
derosa crazy joe joey d because he just
bought a new bronco it's amazing
some car
ridge.com slash hey babe use coupon code
coupon code hey babe to enter that is
com slash hey babe coupon code hey vape
to enter that's right you get your ridge
wallet and you get uh to enter a chance
to win that ford brunch got to do it
okay wait we were just saying
but okay oh the announcement i wanted to
okay so hold okay our father who are in
heaven okay he's in heaven who art in
heaven yeah so is he is he painting no
no no no our father who are in heaven
meaning like
the hallowed halls he has his name his
name is synonymous with he's michael
jordan yeah hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy kingdom come his
kingdom will come thy will be done i i i
will thy will be done like
follow out your
oh i will be done your kingdom will come
to earth that i will
as it is in heaven so in other words the
kingdom of heaven
will when it comes to earth
ain't nothing going to change from what
it's like in heaven to earth ain't none
gonna change um
okay as an earth as
[Music]
this is the remix yeah wait
give us this day thy kingdom come thy
will be done on earth as is in heaven
give us this day oh wait so what's the
one where you say thank you for eating
no i think because he says
the priest usually rips the out father
right before he blesses the eucharist so
give us this day out daily bread so give
us today so basically give us the steak
base give us today our daily bread okay
that is also the body fresh in the
morning give us our daily bread which
you can find daily bread at joey rose's
sandwich shop yes yes you can they break
it their daily give it five stars they
do absolutely usually bread no is that
right are we mixing it up i'll give you
the one heaven halloween and kingdom
come they will be done on earth as it is
in heaven give us this day our daily
bread
i used to say i used literally i here's
what my prayers used to be i used to say
the our father the hail mary the glory
to be and then i would i would always i
don't know where i got taught this i
would always be asked i would always
silently ask for help i would say to
jesus i would say please let there be
peace on earth i would say please let
there be peace on earth i please let me
make the mba and i would always end it
with please let my parents lose the
weight they need to lose to be healthy
again
i swear to god i would say my god yeah
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses give us to say
our daily bread and forgive us our
trespasses so so you've been so
trespassing does that just mean our
you know
our foibles because i don't think that
they're making an entire prayer to
trespassing it's not that like
evidence i was on that guy's lawn yeah
it's not like oh you trespass you don't
have to write credentials give us this
day and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those who trespass against us so
in other words transgressions maybe yeah
they're saying you you you tr and it's
not an eye for an eye it's you trespass
against me i'm gonna choose now to stay
silent everybody forgive each other i've
been trespassed i'll say nothing right
i'll say nothing
mental note
you're not coming on my podcast no but
as we know and and now he's at the act
of contrition and lead us not into
temptation but deliver us
that one okay somebody said let's say
don't tempt me with a good time no
because i'm here for it also now let's
do your prayer the hail mary okay okay
hail mary full of grace the lord is with
thee the hail mary full of grace the
lord is with this i got that so far
uh i don't know the next part i'm
blanking blessed are as soon as as soon
as the hail mary fuller what's gonna
happen is it's like riding a bicycle
soon as hits me i got it hail mary full
of grace the lord is with you nah that's
old blessed are you among women no no
that's not what she has loser d hail
mary full of grace elizabeth d blessed
are you amongst women and blessed is the
fruit i'm gonna update this right now
i'm going to say blessed are you amongst
biological women
i'm updating yeah or yeah blessed are
you biological that certainly was their
intention back then 100 percent yeah the
bible isn't blessed blessed art thou
amongst biological women and blessed is
the fruit of thy womb jesus
hold on a second i don't know this hail
mary full of grace lords with thee
blessed are you amongst women and
blessed is the fruit of thy womb
jesus jesus the fruit of thy womb is
jesus and put a pin in that for a second
i know what we did on christy chaos i'm
gonna blow your [ __ ] balls up with
the da vinci fact in a second here okay
so finish the prayer and then and then
get and then we gotta go back to and
then you better have on you better have
on um
what what's is me undies do they sponsor
hey
not yet
that was like stern eight years ago yeah
all right um holy mary mother of god
pray for our sinners now and at the hour
of our death amen guys pretty
straightforward you know i didn't
realize i didn't know how short that
prayer is do you ever think about like
how god the all-knowing like you know he
knows the hour of your death he's like
this mo don't even know you don't even
know look at him out there
you don't even know he got an hour silly
he got an hour he's out there being
goofy he's out there being goofy he's on
he's in out he's on ig live my man got
an hour he got him out he doesn't even
understand boom bap he's done you don't
even know you got it i can't even
reverse it can it reverse it let me work
yeah put my thing down flip it in
reverse it
my neighbors
um let me tell you something real quick
yes because i also want to do the quick
one the one when you eat because that
one's the one i don't know glory be to
the father no that's glory be it's like
um
bless us oh lord and these thy gifts
right you're about to receive from thy
heaven all right with love and con um
bless us o lord
and these
grace by the way our jewish and muslim
fans have tuned out yes that's true but
we're going to do jewish and muslim
prayers next week yeah on hay babies
stay tuned in we're all together with
the human race that's right all together
now okay well that is what it is that's
what it is bless us o lord and these thy
gifts
these thy gifts that's the one i don't
know which we're about to receive from
thy bounty
and christ our lord amen okay so just
bless us and the food that you gave us
the food blesses the bounty bless us thy
bounty all right through christ our lord
amen all right all right
blow me with the da vinci code can i
just say one thank you
put that in the clip
put that
you have two things to put that in clip
can i just say one thing yes i i i i
need to have sex with jude law there you
go
um um
so okay so blow my balls off with the da
vinci and then go back to wait for
what's happening give me the hat give me
the present moment that's there's no
better moment there's no better moment
than the present
um uh and by can i just cheers you again
because i'm having a great time on our
team oh this is great
um this is how this is how much of an
old man i am i knew we were drinking
wine tonight i brought the ant
smart
you look like
someone is doing you a favor to be
like you look like you
[Laughter]
you look you look
very
[Music]
you look
like
you need a chaperone
yes
so
i
said this the other day on the christmas
podcast but i need to repeat it
leonardo da vinci yeah okay
i never saw the movies
let me tell you something about leonardo
da vinci yeah please number one no last
name
nobody knew his last name leonardo da
vinci is just i'm leonardo of vinci
italy people had last names back then no
not oh [ __ ] he's like beyonce nobody
knows he's like beyonce he's like lizzo
first he was first first
nobody knew anything anything about
where this guy came from nobody knows
it was thought he was one of the only
painters that was famous during his
lifetime 10 years of his life
unaccounted for like jesus christo
um um
uh jesus people was so next level with
his art inventions people now scientists
today think
like literal i'm talking about not
kooks i'm talking about mit scientists
are like he was abducted by aliens
they or he time traveled that's the only
there's no other way that he would know
that at 500 years ago wow i don't know
how do i not know this
first version of the helicopter leonardo
da vinci first first version of a diving
suit leonardo da vinci first version of
an airplane leonardo da vinci paintings
bicycle he would war machine dude you
know he invented he had like weapons of
war the italian government was like you
need to make war weapons this guy was
making war weapons that were like
cannon you know 360 degrees
huh painting them
illustrating them just writing them down
he made tanks uh first illustrations for
tanks
what he would do was because he was a
pacifist he would make an illustration
for a tank and and a huge um crossbow
but leave out
leave out ingredients that you needed he
would leave out he would do the opposite
of what hellofresh did hellofresh gives
you all the ingredients right and if you
go to if you go to hellofresh.com you
put in hey babe 16 get 16 free gifts 20
and 30 minutes
all that but how hey hello fresh is a
great job because they are america's
number one meal kid giving you every
ingredient da vinci would leave out a
couple because he didn't want man to
have the power that he knew and hits it
he didn't want you to know how you can
kill all these [ __ ]
so so
so he would draw a tank but not the not
the [ __ ] thing yes
he would he would leave out key parts
but this is not even the thing i want to
tell you about okay i'm just one i just
want to set the stage for lean on today
you draw a bicycle with one wheel and
then i can't even realize that's how the
unicycle came about yeah he had to know
that he actually made it worse okay
he when he was a young man
it was very common in italy to have an
apprentice so he was he was this
painter's apprentice very famous painter
at the times apprentice shout out donald
trump shout out donald trump
he was the apprentice to donald to the
donald trump of his time right
now when you were an apprentice in
1500's italy you were asked to
you know just kind of help out you would
never be given the task of painting like
a uh an actual part of the painting
you're giving the telling you're giving
them the colors you're mixing the thing
you're kind of watching and learning
whatever
they're painting this painting leonardo
da vinci says you know
i wanna it was the painting is called
the ascension or the enunciation i'm
sorry the enunciation which is the
painting of the angel coming down from
heaven to tell mary mother of god how to
pronounce
words exactly right the enunciation the
enunciation he was saying he was saying
it's um what was the word that we always
he was saying he was saying it was not
it was saying it's allegedly allegedly
but he was saying that it's um what was
the word remember a few episodes ago
last year
we've done 93 of them so remember there
was a word that we mispronounced oh yeah
what was the word oh yeah we made it up
we made it up and we told people to
start using it and they did
man
i wish i didn't have adhd but i couldn't
tell i do but it's not but the same way
that we've told you to make a video make
a video of your favorite moment of hey
babe uh and you will win this hat is
that word right you'll tell us about
you'll call us idiots and rightfully so
we deserve to be called idiots for not
remembering this word we do apologize
the enunciation but the enunciation he
taught people how to say pterodactyl
pterodactyl which on wednesday okay so
he the what that is is the angel which
is up right here the angel that's the
angel telling mary this is telling mary
that she's about to be impregnated
against her will with jesus okay so
she's about to get divine intervention
get the immaculate conception that's
good or bad news for mary at face value
i think mary might have said to herself
at that point i'll do this but imagine
mary said i'll do it but i'm an
alcoholic
like i'm gonna have to go through
imagine mayor was like i'm gonna have to
go through rehab first it's a lot it's a
lot but it is it's a lot to lay on
someone
out of nowhere you're going to not even
know that
your husband joseph is too old for this
[ __ ] right so you're going to have to
now explain like the lover and let the
how you got pregnant
do you think when mary do you think when
mary came on and said i'm pregnant it's
immaculate conception that angel came
down and gave it to me joseph said i'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you yeah
because you cheated that means you
cheated on me i literally think the
first thing he did was ask for maury
povich yeah the other thing
more he's like you are the father
now let's say there's a reboot and the
angel says this to you what do you guys
do
oh
well to be honest with you
i think at this point you mean
impregnating me as a man yes i might i
might politely refuse
i might
i understand the honor but the wait i
have i'm so busy yeah and i i really am
and i have so much stress already that
i'm already working on yeah stress and
anxieties which is why a day like
today's 93 episode like a spa day for us
is so important i have so many stresses
i'm working on to add
birthing
the savior of eternity of the you know
it's it's a lot i would ask you know i
would say i would be on i'd i would use
you know what the recent events i'd say
you know you know being pregnant at this
time is not there is still an active
pandemic going on
and i you know i i know that you are the
son of god and and you've been sent down
from heaven but if you can't give me a
guarantee that this is going to be good
for my for my health and happiness then
i just can't do it right and honestly
you'd be within reason we've come a long
way and progressing as a society back
then it's like you had to just do it and
you didn't have to maybe you couldn't
use your voice now if the angel said i
hear what you're saying chris but i'm
about to give you point three
point three money oh
right now no epidural no epidural
right now i'm literally literally i will
shoot jesus out of my vagina yeah i will
cash i would say you know what let it
drip out
literally
i said to the angel i said i got i got
three words for you fill me up yeah
trust me yo what does it say on the
bill babe and god we trust absolutely i
trust you yeah if you give me the point
three i would say you could put it in my
ass i don't care yeah what yeah
so the 0.3 is a reference to 300 million
dollars that elon musk has yes uh 257
billion points 0.3 billion but you
become the biggest influencer in the
world overnight
yes i would say i yeah
that's what the child does the child
well you're gonna have nine months of
dope content true i know i would be like
oh my god i'm the next logan paul i
would i i would say i would name the kid
logan paul
that is sick content dude sick content
okay let me tell you the the mind the
the mind-blowing fact another round come
on babe come on
pimp
do you want it
there it is get a little buzz why not
um
so
you ready
go get in there
um
i
i
so so you know the the painter leonardo
da vinci's you know apprentice whatever
da vinci out of nowhere says you know
they're painting this famous painting
the enunciation which is like i said the
angel giving mary the news of you're
about to be the immaculate conception
da vinci says
do you mind if i paint the angel
which is kind of crazy thing for an 18
19 year old kid to say to his
uh apprentice uh you know to his to his
to his boss or whatever and he's the
apprentice davinci is the apprentice so
to what is so what would that what would
that make him the the mentor the opener
the mentee the men yeah the opener you
know da vinci's the opener
is the apprentice mentor so what is his
boss as the mentor yeah so normally the
mentor
99 out of a hunch would say
are you [ __ ] out of your mind right
how about i behead you right head i'm
i'm not the mentor you know whatever
your time paparazzo yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna paint this right for whatever
reason
and
even in his life years later the the
mentor says i don't know why i let him
paint that angel because it went out to
become a famous painting but
but the mind blowing was ballsy it was
supposed to be but the mind-blowing fact
of the painting wouldn't be discovered
for another 500 years what i'm about to
tell you
he paints
they use lead paint
oh wow everybody use lead paint at this
time everybody use lead leads that's
some paint that's that's bad lead paint
which is not good
lead paint they all used it okay
the only painting
da vinci
ever stop it the only thing he ever
painted in his life in his career
without a lead-based paint
is that angel in that painting the
enunciation get out of here okay why
500 years later
a little thing known as the x-ray was
invented when you x-ray what is that
okay an x-ray here we go hurt yourself
if you ever next daily
if if you got a bone bruise or a bone
fracture they put you under these lights
called x-ray lights and it can see
inside your body whoa
when you x-ray this isn't this is
you can do that anyone can do that
anyone can do it okay
x-men x-rays devil race
ray liotta oh like x-ray vision x-rays
what that means same thing you could see
i could see through you okay
when you x-ray
the painting of the enunciation
depicting the angel i don't i can't
impregnating mary now
the angel disappears underneath the
x-ray because of the type of pain
leonardo da vinci used for the one time
in his career the one time in his life
the one art the one part of that
painting that would make sense to
disappear because there is no way for
people to see the angel she was
immaculately conceived the angel goes
bye-bye under x-ray
explain it
explain it
i can't
nobody can wild
another thing
when you 3d
reverse image
most of da vinci's paintings guess what
you see
demon
the same demon
over and over and over again what the
same demon with its eyes looking google
leonardo da vinci demon paintings demons
why haven't i heard of this because i'm
here to tell you
demon
no yep what's this code
is that [ __ ] is that just a movie
yeah is that really a book or is it
really a code
the mona lisa is demons it was just a
book
no google did google demon in davinci
paintings 3d
uh 3d or 2d yeah
there's a demon when you put them when
you 2d when when you put them together
like it's a whole
it's a whole thing
da vinci after dark is a porn website
um
also the mona lisa for no reason took
him 16 years to shout out
shout out slick rick mona lisa 16 years
to finish no reason why the very last
painting he did finished it died two
days later
oh no
[Music]
get them get out of here really i feel
like i would know that i feel like
davinch
have you seen the mona lisa in purse i
have small right i saw it in 2000 uh
fall 2018. small it's it's literally
like an eight by ten
it's an eight by ten bro so small it's
crazy it took him 16 years to nobody no
explanation why it took him 16 years he
just how did he know he finished it he
told somebody yeah he hit all the
messages in he had so many messages in
it there's like a there's like math
that's what the code is
it's in the mona lisa
wow
so they they
who is this guy
leonardo da vinci yeah like so is was he
like some type of uh
so that's what they think they think how
does he how how did no one knows
they literally modern science like
actual not kooks
regular scientists that said not cuckoo
banana people the only explanation is in
those 10 years that his life was
unaccounted for
because he journaled everything except
for these 10 years the only thing that
is is that he was abducted by aliens and
thrown into the future and then thrown
back
that's our explanation
and nobody since him wow this is wild
stuff
makes you want to read more
well i feel like i should know that
stuff you know what you know what
youtube channel i watch all day weird
history i'm sure that you do weird
history
wild stuff to know
you know like um you know diabetes and
all this stuff and sug it's all been
around from there you know diabetes it's
all been around from the beginning from
the beginning no
so let me tell you nothing nothing is
new nothing so whatever problem you're
having understand it's just a re-vamped
version of the same problem people had
300 years ago history repeats hallelujah
as as as marcus aurelius said
in
2000 years ago
people are people
depeche mode also said that people are
people people are people so what should
it be
you and i should get along so um
um
wow that's something else
i'm really i'm really having a relaxed
fun day
this has been one of the moat
to go out in 93.
we didn't we didn't taste
the hot sauce we didn't play the mad
libs
because the thing is when you come into
our world for an hour of your time each
week
there there are no rules i it's it's
meditation
i'm saying to you
whatever way you want to experience this
whatever ride you want to take that's up
to you there's no right or wrong answers
here at the hay bay podcast no right or
wrong answers wow this has been like
this is really a nice it's really a nice
day i think this is going to be pleasant
for the listeners i think people are
going to come away today learning
something i don't think they're going to
feel relaxed because we're exuding that
energy and i think that you know i think
that you've if you come around for this
hour to hang with us i think you're
leaving uh you know an entertained
better more well-rounded person why
don't you tell us what your relaxation
techniques are what you do to calm down
and have a you day a girl day and us day
what face product what face masks you
like to put on yeah how you wrap your
head in a towel
yeah
that's really it that's i mean what kind
of wine you like to drink from new
zealand yes what do you think of da
vinci and and did he time travel yeah
hey just so write to us online
what wine do you like what do you think
about da vinci what do you do for a
girls day spa day you day what kind of
mask do you use
hey babe hey babe that's the hashtag in
addition to hashtag hey babe
no stupid hat hey babe stupid hat hey
baby stephen had a stupid hat hey hey
babe stupid hat hashtag hey babe stupid
hat one of you is going to be wearing
the hat that krista stefano is wearing
right now i'm sweating in it bad
yes
what about what about what is one what
was your ready for this yeah what was if
and this is a hard question i've asked
you this before
your whole week yeah your whole week
what was the best minute
of the week
what happened in that minute just and
and it should come to your mind
relatively quickly because the truth
will come to
the front of your head the quickest it's
it's difficult it's easy to say best day
best hour what's the one minute let's
make our life small i know it the best
minute
it's wrapping up one of my favorite
episodes right this second
this has been hey
babe don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe